Wayne Smith when he came here we had you
make signature blades in your signature
Style that's not going to happen at home
instead you'll be making this weapon
from Greek mythology
the sword of Perseus
next pre-test is a sword of Perseus
oh here we are Clash of the Titans and
all this history of the Greek mythology
it was a fun sword to wield simply
because I'm attacking something that's
supposed to be Medusa
to cut everything in without looking in
the rice so I don't turn to Stone
the goal is it hard to do actually in my
training I don't look at my target I'll
mark a Target but once I've marked it
I'm ready to go I look somewhere else
I'm constantly looking at another Target
because once I see this I hit that I
gotta be I'm constantly using it for a
full vision because that's combat you
look at multiple opponents so looking at
the Target now says hey Doc don't look
at Medusa's eyes I'm like sure I
actually don't
this is our first female ballistics
dummy actually having Medusa there but
what made it easier was just look at the
snakes in her head she's not that pretty
ready
with Perseus sword it wasn't just about
cutting Medusa's head
we're still feeling all the different
damage you can do how does this weapon
feel when I'm cutting
can I recover fast as I'm doing all
these different cuts I'm testing the
balance I'm testing the edge I'm testing
how it affects what I'm cutting and then
of course for the fun part
head off
[Music]
son of Zeus the Greek demigod Perseus is
best known for decapitating the Gorgon
Medusa with his mighty sword
the legendary weapon is described as
having a short leaf-shaped blade that
was perfect for cutting slashing and
thrusting
Perseus was given this blade by the
Greek goddess Athena who wanted Medusa
destroyed
later in the myth Perseus used the head
of Medusa to turn the massive crack and
sea monster to Stone saving the princess
Andromeda
though the story is fiction you can
watch Perseus slay Medusa in the film
Clash of the Titans or visit renowned
artist Benvenuto Cellini's bronze
depiction in Florence Italy make a sword
worthy of the Gods
and your panel of expert judges and the
title of Forge and fire champion
we'll see you in four days good luck
my name is Jared ball 36 years old from
Tomball Texas people ask me all the time
like what got you into doing this I'm
like I don't know you know just watching
some YouTube videos of somebody they
were melting aluminum got drafted out of
high school and ended up playing minor
league baseball for about 10 years I'm
always trying to not lose I don't care
about winning I just don't want to lose
going with the adcrv too it's a good
steal it's tough it holds a good Edge
for me the most difficult part of
forging the sword is that getting the
curves and The Hourglass shape to it I'm
already getting kind of thin in the
belly up here where I need it
[Music]
so I'm kind of trying to avoid having to
get the blade too thin
so I'm getting ready to quench as I heat
the sword up for the quench I had never
done one this big especially in my Forge
like this it's a lot smaller so I'm had
to kind of go back and forth and move it
in and out and get an even Heat
barely got the whole Edge in there
yes
I'll take it the heat treat's done I'm
gonna start working on the guard I'm
gonna use the Damascus just because I
want to do something a little different
there we go and I wanted to basically
make things harder on myself the pommels
attached now the Horseshoe guards are
attached I got to fit the wood basically
in between the two my sword it's a home
run hopefully it's enough to where I can
win the game girls what do y'all think
of Daddy's sword
kill
[Music]
it's day one my name is Rob Wayman I'm
from Middleburg New York I'm 35 years
old I got into bladesmithing a few years
back I was watching forest and fire and
I kept saying over and over that I could
probably do this better than the people
on the show and eventually my wife said
well do it so I just need to do this I'm
gonna try to make my blade out of
Damascus I've got 1084
I've got 15 and 20. I'm just gonna go
for a random pattern Damascus start
working this Billet cut it restack it
and Forge weld again I got my Billet
with my uh 1084 core and we're heading
in the Ford I'm moving a ton of Steel
I'm going from the Press I'm going to
the Anvil and then bam my press is down
it is going to put me really really
behind ah yeah I got nothing it's all
alarmed from here on out
the Tang took a bit of time to get drawn
out not having that press is costing me
precious time
it's going to be a fight to the Finish
yesterday the heat treat
came out perfect
yes
handle assembly went great I've got my
pins in but it's a heavy sword so the
rest of my time is going to be hogging
with more material off
arms feel like they're about ready to
fall off
pattern looks amazing my only regret is
that I couldn't get more weight off of
it
I don't want to see I'm turning through
a rock
all right blade Smith welcome to the
kill test
now in Greek mythology Perseus uses
sword to decapitate Medusa roof her head
from her body to use it as a weapon to
that end I will take your weapon and
help me to deliver some killing slashes
and blows to liberate her head from her
body Robert you're up first you ready
for this yes sir let's do this going
into testing I am concerned about the
weight I'm hoping my blade can do
everything that Doug wants it to do but
I'm concerned
[Music]
good
all right Robert let's talk about your
sword here I like the design that you
have of the Damascus
in there
but it's so heavy it's about five pounds
over here but the thing is it's so
forward heavy most of the weights up
here when I'm lifting this I can feel
all the stress right there this is
supposed to be meant to be a
single-handed use weapon now your Edge
is plenty sharp it was easy to thrust
and cut and
it will kill
all right Jared to your turn you ready
sir yes sir let's do this with the test
you never really know what to expect and
anything can go wrong
[Music]
all right Jared first up you nailed the
balance on this as a one-handed sword
it's about three pounds lighter than
your opponents your Edge is razor sharp
every slash is deep the thrust no issues
at all and most importantly sir
it will kill
all right bladesmith next stop is the
strength Desk release the Jamie Meter
all right bladesmiths we took Medusa's
head during the kill test now the
Krakens Turn to Stone so what I'm going
to do is take your swords and beat them
mercilessly into these Stone cracking
heads
it's gonna be brutal
and Rob you're up first how you feeling
a little nervous but I'm ready let's do
it this is the make or break test
[Music]
you okay nope bounced off the glove
didn't cut me
[Music]
what's up
my blade breaks my heart breaks but I am
just so glad that it didn't hurt Jay
oh a little bit of a problem here Rob
on the Tang you can see a black spot so
it means you had a stress fracture there
with the weight of this sword hitting
those Stone cracking skulls it was
enough to allow that stress fracture to
just continue all the way across so
the good part is that your Edge
held up so good job on the Damascus but
it's kind of hard to swing a sword but a
handle on it
well Robert your blade broke after four
strokes on this crack and head but that
doesn't mean that you're out of the
competition Jared your blade still has
to survive four strikes Jay let's get
crack-a-lackin
this is it right here let's see what it
did to Rob's blade my sword's got to
hold up four swings and I know Jay you
know he's going to try to do some damage
[Music]
Jared your blade survived Robert
unfortunately your blade cannot continue
to be tested in this competition and for
that reason I have to ask you to please
leave before to come on forward my
friend you killed the Medusa though
it's a heartbreaker but I'm really proud
of what I did
Jerry
congratulations the strength of your
weapon has ensured that you are the
forced to fire Champion leaving this
forage with a check for ten thousand
dollars good job brother awesome thank
you
how you feeling right now good how about
a smile or something yeah
all right come on over and Shake our
hands brother good job man good job
I am the new forged and fire Champion
something I never thought I'd say
I can't wait to get home give my
daughters in the news and uh take the 10
grand take my family on a vacation
somewhere
thank you